An increasingly popular technique in new product development...
...is what has come to be known as "ethnography".
A term that grew out of the field of anthropology...
..and it's just an academic-sounding word for observational research.
Why do it? Well, I think the notion is that sometimes there's a huge departure...
...between what people say they do versus what they actually do.
And the only way we would know this, of course, is through observation.
Another problem is that there are some needs that we refer to as unarticulated needs.
There are things the customer doesn't even think about,...
...and in a straight conversational interview, might never bring up.
I'll give a couple of examples of that. We were, many years ago,...
...working with a division of Baxter on a new dialysis machine.
And one of the things that no customer ever brought up but which we observed is...
...that during a dialysis treatment, the nurses have to be writing a lot of things down.
And they seem to be going ridiculous distances across the clinic...
...just to find a flat surface on which to write something down.
Nobody ever brought it up, but we observed it time and time again.
And what my client ultimately did was they put a flat shelf on top of the machine...
...that was just incredibly popular, even though it had been totally unarticulated.
Now, of course, once you've brought it up with people, yeah, they recognized it immediately.
"Yeah, I always go all the way over to the nurses station just to write something down."
There's also, again, this disconnect between what they do and what they say they do.